Hello Freak bitches 30 the last time I sat a exactly 30 last time I had a three
month retreat.
Um,
but he's just got you,
you're unplugging from your life.
You're saying goodbye to everyone,
you know,
if you,
for all,
you know someone's going to die while you're on retreat.
And so there's this real discontinuity with every project and every aspiration
and everything you have going on.
Um,
and,
and also most of the people in your life can't believe you're doing this.
It's,
there's not much support.
You know,
it's like it's just totally inscrutable.
Yeah.
That you would decide to do this and then you'll essentially lock yourself in a
closet.
I mean,
a lot.
You essentially lock yourself in a room as big as,
you know,
these two tables and then you're just left with your thoughts.
And the,
the problem is,
is that just thinking itself,
even thinking happy thoughts is stressful at when you,
when you actually,
when you really start paying attention to it,
that,
that just the sheer automaticity of it to just,
just to be,
just to not be able to stop the conversation.
And he just can't stop talking to yourself for a second.
And that now you eventually you can eventually you become concentrated on,
in this case,
uh,
the,
the practice I was doing as it's called Vipassana,
which is mindfulness meditation and the practice there is just to become very
keenly aware of,
uh,
you start with the breath as an object of meditation.
But,
but once you get a little concentration,
you opened it up to everything.
So sounds and sensations and even thoughts themselves become objects of
meditation where you're just noticing whatever arises in consciousness and,
but the difference between noticing the thought arise and pass away and being
lost in thought is,
is huge and this is the all important difference.
And it takes some real concentration to act,
to see a thought arise and pass away because without the concentration,
all of a sudden the thoughts just you,
it just comes up from behind in a way and you are just,
you're just,
you feel identical in,
in a strange way.
You feel identical to this sentence in your head.
You Do,
you feel there's miss thoughts are just sentences and images.
I mean,
it's,
when you actually look at what a thought is,
it's very hard to see how you could,
how could ever define your subjectivity in the first place.
It's just like mere thoughts are no more substantial than the sound of my voice.
And you're just hearing the sound of my voice as a kind of appearance and
consciousness right now.
And it's not,
it's not defining you.
It's not,
you don't feel identical to it.
It doesn't have a real implication so much for how you feel.
Uh,
you're,
you're not,
uh,
it's just,
it's easy to see or to in this case here that it is a,
an just an appearance in consciousness.
It comes and it goes,
it starts and it stops.
And it's all sort of in plain view.
But with your own thoughts with the w w with your own voice,
it,
it sneaks up on you in a way that is,
and even to use
the word you in this case is a little misleading because it,
but it,
it colors consciousness and trims it down in such a way that it just feels like
you.
It doesn't,
it doesn't feel it does it,
it's,
it's you,
you feel,
I mean the feeling of being a self,
the feeling that we call I,
the feeling of being an ego in the head is what it feels like to be thinking
without knowing that you're thinking.
It's the,
it's the feeling of this next thought.
Capturing consciousness.
So when you say that thoughts,
you are identical to thought.
So if you're thinking something really fucked up like a,
I'm fat,
I'm a loser,
I'm always going to be a loser.
Like that is identical to who you are because you are sort of framing yourself
in this thought that these thoughts that you're carrying around in your mind,
they are what's occupying your consciousness.
And the,
if those thoughts are on the forefront of your consciousness,
that they identify you,
you are,
that you are those thoughts and you are identical to that idea.
Yeah.
And their,
and their driving behavior and they're driving emotion and they're driving each
subsequent train of thought.
So it's,
it's just,
it's determining the future expressions of your consciousness and your body as
well.
So you're,
you're,
and again,
I'm not,
I'm not separating the mind from the body here.
I mean all of this is,
we could talk about this in terms of events in the brain as well,
but it's much easier to talk about it in terms of our first person experience
has thoughts and moods and emotions,
et cetera.
But,
um,
you know,
for the,
for the purpose of this argument,
you know,
there's no doubt that the brain is doing this.
It's just,
we're not that side of the story as much less to say about that side of the
story at the moment.
And it's not clean is doing it,
but you're,
you're whatever it is,
your personality,
your consciousness,
your,
your center is sort of what guides the brain one way or another.
Like it is possible to,
while in the middle of having these thoughts and say,
you know what,
I'm not gonna entertain these anymore and I'm going to think about something
positive.
But it's very difficult.
Yeah.
Surprisingly difficult.
Even as someone like myself who's spent a lot of times,
a lot of time meditating,
especially a lot of time in isolation tanks,
I,
it's still difficult every now and then if something's bothering you to just get
it out of your head.
Like,
especially for me.
Um,
one of my main issues is my work.
like,
uh,
like standup comedy for instance.
Like if I have a show and a I fuck a bit up.
If it goes wrong,
like if I have two shows in a night and I fuck a bit up on the first show,
I'm okay.
If I could redo it on the second show,
we're good.
But if I fuck it up on the second show,
God damn it.
Now I have to think about that thing all night and I'll try to let it go.
I'll try to get it out of my head.
But I rationalize it by saying the only reason why I've gotten so good is
because of this crazy obsession that I have with getting it correct.
And that when things go awry or when I go down a bad path,
it doesn't quite pan out.
And then I have to sort of restart the whole conversation on stage that,
that uncomfortable moment.
And then the subsequent uncomfortable recollection of that moment is the very
motivation that's led me to be a good standup in the first place.
So I kind of rationalize it,
but fuck man,
when I'm eating dinner after a show and I just flubbed one word that fucks up a
joke,
I'll be in the middle of eating pancakes going,
shit,
I can't get it out of my head.
It doesn't matter if a wonderful wife and a beautiful family and great friends
and a fantastic job and a one wonder of just a fee,
a dream life,
it doesn't matter.
I flubbed a word.
You fucking idiot.
You know,
like while I'm cutting into my food.
Ah,
well that,
that,
that's an interesting moment because,
um,
so there's a moment before the thought has arisen,
right,
where you have not yet remembered the flip lines.
So you're just cutting into your dinner and then it's it,
it's an image or part image,
part sentence,
something.
There's some expression of thought that arises in consciousness and you are,
you,
you do not,
you do not witness it arise.
It's not like it's a difference between seeing it,
watching a movie and being totally lost in the movie.
Forgetting that you're sitting in a room with a bunch of other people looking at
light on a wall.
You're just,
you're totally captured by the movie.
It's different between that and actually just seeing the screen,
the light on the wall,
hearing the sound of the projector,
seeing,
seeing the artifice and uh,
it's possible to see thoughts just as essentially like a play of light on the
wall.
He just use,
you see it before it captures you.
And the difference is total.
And it is kind of like,
it's almost like playing a video game where you can now not get killed in the
same spot over and over again.
It's like there's like not losing in the same boss fight over and over again.
Yet we,
we lose in that same fight a thousand times a day.
But when you can actually see thoughts for what they are,
so the next time you flubbed a line and the next and the next time you recall
it,
it's possible with an a,
and again,
it takes a certain degree of concentration to be able to do this,
but concentration becomes kind of a native capacity.
At a certain point.
It's like Jujitsu or anything else.
I,
you have certain skills and you don't really lose them.
Um,
then you can just see it and it just comes and it goes and it doesn't have an
end and it's going,
it's going,
it's really gone.
It's,
it's,
and it doesn't have the same emotional necessity.
It doesn't trigger the same mental state.
And now that's not to say that these negative mental states haven't had the,
the benefit that you ascribe to them.
So yeah,
it could be that you are as good as you are because you were motivated to not
embarrass yourself ever again because it felt so terrible.
Right?
So you hated this experience of flubbing align.
You hated the memory of,
of,
and the of it the next day
you hated what it did to your,
your time with your family.
And so he thought,
I'm not even the next tour.
I'm going to get this.
I'm going to,
I'm going to get up earlier.
I'm going to work harder,
et cetera.
So yeah,
that,
that's all part of the,
the clockwork that's causing you to,
to hone your craft.
Um,
but I would argue that a little mental suffering goes along way.
I think we w you know,
nine times out of 10 or 99 times out of a hundred,
we suffer unnecessarily and there's no good comes from it.
It's just,
it's,
it's not actually making us better people.
It's making us more neurotic.
People were more worried.
We're worse.
Husbands were worse fathers and,
and it's time to,
to break that spell and,
and,
and then you can,
you can selectively be as,
as uptight and neurotic as you want,
but you can,
it gives you a kind of freedom to pick your,
your,
um,
your priorities in a way rather than be captured by just whatever the next
thought happens to be.
I've also found for me personally,
the discipline and diligence or the,
the best mitigating factors for dealing with a neurotic thoughts.
Like if I have an issue,
um,
one of the big issues if I've ever had anything go wrong was that I didn't work
hard enough.
So if I know for a fact that I worked as hard as I could,
like back when I was competing,
that was a huge issue.
And it also,
uh,
mitigated nervousness.
Cause Look,
whenever you're involved in a competition as terrifying as a full contact
martial arts tournament where concussions are not just likely,
but it's someone in,
there's a hundred people fighting in this tournament,
someone's going to sleep,
someone's going to get knocked out because it going to be you and someone's
going to get their nose broken.
Someone's going to get hit.
A lot of people are probably,
if I,
if I trained really hard,
if like I know I did everything that I could,
I ate right,
I slept right.
I put in all the practice,
I worked on all my weaknesses.
I,
you know,
I didn't neglect my strengths.
I was much less nervous,
much less nervous and much better at dealing with losses.
Whereas losses,
uh,
I think losses for martial artists can be insanely devastating.
Like A,
I was listening to this interview with Travis Brown,
you know,
he has no UFC heavyweight,
one of the top,
top five guys in the world,
great fighter lost recently to Fabricio for doom.
Okay.
Any title elimination fight.
So Fabrisio has gone on and he'll be fighting Cain Velasquez for the heavyweight
title.
Now in October in Mexico and a huge October or November,
November,
believe it's November.
What are one of those?
Um,
he's fighting a Cain Velasquez for the title.
Huge fight.
It could've been Travis Browne,
Travis Browne lost the fight by decision and you know,
it was,
uh,
he lost without a doubt.
But you know,
wasn't embarrassing.
It wasn't a,
he didn't get knocked out in the first round.
He didn't get submitted really quickly,
but he did lose the fight and it was apparently devastating to him.
I mean,
he's in great depth
about lying in bed in the fetal position crying.
I mean his fucking 250 pound gladiator and he's curled up in a fetal position
crying.
I mean,
the truth is I have to,
the ego is always curled up in the fetal position crying.
We all have that
part of ourselves and it's,
um,
yeah,
I mean that,
and that's what is so excruciating about the self and the self really is the
center of the center of our problem.
You know,
and,
and when things are really going well,
we are consoled by how well they're going.
But we know it's,
it's vulnerable to change.
I mean,
you're only as good as your last appearance in some sense.
I could do something incredibly embarrassing in the middle of this podcast and
that will be the thing I'm thinking about tonight.
And I'll be,
I'm thinking,
you know,
God,
I can't believe I fucked that up so bad and Joe's podcast.
Uh,
and that it's,
you're always vulnerable to that for the recipe for it.
As long as you,
as long as you're in the center of this thing,
vulnerable to what other other people think about you and,
um,
a captive of your really crazy rehearsal of experience.
And when you,
when something like this happens to you,
just think of how many times you repeat it to yourself.
It's like you tell yourself the same story 15 times a minute for hours and it
doesn't strike you as insane,
but it actually is insane.
It's,
I,
if you're,
if you are thoughts could be broadcast on a monitor for other people to hear and
they could hear you repeat yourself over and over and over again.
It would seem starkly crazy.
It just it and yet it seems normal.
It's,
it's kind of like,
like the dream state where you go to sleep and you're in your bed and you,
you know,
you're,
everything's obeying the laws of physics.
And then in the next conscious moment you are,
you know,
at a party somewhere,
it's talking to someone who you know,
is dead and saying,
oh,
I can't believe you're,
you're alive now.
And,
and,
and then you know,
there's a gorilla in the room and,
and,
and none of this strikes you as crazy.
It's the craziest things about dreams is that the mind seems to just accept them
except these changes one after the other without any sense.
That there should be continuity and this is due.
There's no question that this is due to the diminished activity of the frontal
lobes dirt during rem sleep and that we just,
our truth or reality testing hardware has come largely offline during dreams.
But there's something analogous happening when we're just thinking in the waking
state because thoughts are,
thoughts don't make much sense because the,
the repetition is we don't notice how crazy the repetition is.
And we would notice it if we were talking to each other.
If I was telling you the same thing 15 times in a row without a,
without honoring your expectation that I might move on to another topic,
you know,
you would,
you would notice and I would notice.
Right?
Um,
and uh,
yeah.
And,
and the other thing that's crazy about thoughts is that much of our thinking and
certainly our linguistic thoughts,
or it's structured as though it were a conversation and we played both sides of
the conversation.
So I,
you know,
I'll,
I'll sit down here and,
um,
you know,
I said I came in,
I sat down and,
uh,
I brought you a book and I wanted to sign the book and I see this pen over here
and,
and I think,
Oh,
good.
There's a pen over there right now.
I can see that there's a pen over there.
So who am I?
Why do I have to say there's a pen over there,
right?
Who am I telling?
Is there someone in me who can't see that there's a pen over there?
Right?
So there's a conversation that started like,
and I'm both sides of it,
that doesn't make any sense.
Right?
And,
and yet we are,
our subjectivity is continually,
uh,
just,
it is,
it is discursive in that way and they're just voices talking to each other.
And there's not only,
not only are there not to have us in there,
there's not even one of us in there.
There's not,
the thinker isn't there,
but we seem to have two of them.
It's like we're constantly talking to mommy and Daddy.
Uh,
and in fact,
I could be the way this conversation gets internalized,
cause you know,
I can see it in my kids now where they seem to all the Aleve,
you know,
I'll listen to my daughter or playing by herself and she's talking to herself
out loud in the way that,
that,
you know,
you'd have to be sort of crazy to do as an adult.
But as a kid,
you're just,
you know,
you're just talking out loud.
Um,
and eventually we all learned to internalize that conversation.
But,
um,
and when you don't,
when people who can't internalize it will,
they're the crazy ones.
You know,
the,
the person who's walking down the street just saying,
oh good,
there's a pen over there and what w God,
we're late.
And,
uh,
God,
I know Joe Joe is gonna really be pissed.
Um,
I can't believe I sh I should have checked the traffic before I left.
So these are the kinds of thoughts I could think silently in,
in,
in the space of my mind.
But,
um,
and it wouldn't be starkly crazy,
but to verbalize them then you're a madman.
And that,
that difference between letting them out and just knowing to keep your mouth
shut is it captures a,
a large part of the difference between being,
you know,
uh,
a proper lunatic,
and in normal person.
But what I argue in this book is that it's normal isn't good enough.
You know,
the normal,
the normal state of consciousness wherein you are just chased out of bed every
morning by your thoughts and you think,
think,
think every waking moment until you fall helplessly asleep at night.
Um,
that's not necessarily a happy place to be.
And it's not the only alternative.
And,
and so,
um,
and again,
and thought it's not that you're,
the goal is not to have a mind without thoughts,
but we need thoughts and you can't,
you know,
everything we do as human beings for the most part d requires thought to get off
the ground.
So our relationships are based on thoughts and our every public institution and
science.
It's all,
it's this conversation we have with ourselves and with others is based on,
on language,
uh,
almost an a and a and concepts that are mediated by language.
And,
uh,
so you need thought.
But the difference is the difference is between thinking and knowing that you're
thinking in really knowing that you're thinking in the moment of thoughts
arising or being lost in thought.
And then when you're lost in thought,
it doesn't really matter what the content is.
You're still confused about who and what you are.
I mean,
you gotta be thinking about then what you can be thinking about the most
profound things in science or in,
in ethics or whatever it is.
But if you're just thinking without knowing that you're thinking there is a kind
of delusion there,
it is analogous to the dream state in a way where you're just,
you're not,
it's not clear to you what's going on youth,
the youth that you think you are the thinker of the thoughts,
you think you're offering your thoughts in a way that's you're,
you're not,
I mean,
cause thoughts just arrives.
We don't,
we don't actually offer them
[inaudible]
yeah.